And good day to you members of our Sum
TV family. This is I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program. You
send in Bible- based questions. By the
grace of God, we promise Bible-based
answers. My name is CA Murray and I'm in
the presence of Pastor Steven Boore and
Pastor David Salazar. Gentlemen, thank
you for joining me on the panel today.
It's a pleasure.
>> It's a pleasure, pastor, to be with you.
>> You send in your Bible questions. We
give you Bible answers. You can do so by
writing to TV at some su m as in
marytv.org.
That's tvsum
as in mary.orgg.
And we will give you the Bible-based
answers to those questions. Now, after
we have prayer, Pastor Boore, if you
would pray for us. We're going to go
back and pick up a little bit from our
last program because we didn't get a
chance to thoroughly answer this
question that came to us from South
Africa.
>> Let's pray.
Father in heaven, we come before your
awesome throne and we come boldly
because we come in the name of Jesus.
But we also come humbly realizing that
our knowledge is so limited compared to
yours. We have so many questions, many
of which will never be answered as long
as we walk on this earth before the
second coming. How we look forward to
that day when we're in heaven and we'll
be able to have Jesus as our teacher.
Then all of our questions will be
answered.
>> I ask Lord that you will bless us with
our limited knowledge in our program
today. Give us divine wisdom to speak.
Bless all of those who watch the
program. We pray in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen.
This question, as we mentioned, came to
us from South Africa. It is rather
lengthy, so I'm not going to reread all
of it because it is indeed rather
lengthy. Um, he does have three bullet
points at the end that I think we can
address uh in sequence. Does Jesus see
what is happening here on earth or does
he see through the Holy Spirit? One.
Two, is he only relying on his
fornowledge? and three and maybe if you
can also address the last part of the
godhead as you answer the first
question. So basically Christ his
knowledge holy spirit fornowledge and uh
dealing with the godhead as we work our
way through all of these.
>> Yeah I think I think the first thing
that we need to do uh is um read
revelation chapter 1 verses 1 and two
where we have the fact that god works
with a chain of command.
>> Correct. Uh I'm right there, pastor.
I'll read Revelation 1:es 1 and two. And
it says, "The revelation of Jesus
Christ, which God gave him to show his
servants things which must shortly take
place. And he sent and signified by his
angel to his servant John, who bore
witness to the world, to the word of
God, and the testimony of Jesus Christ,
to all things that he saw."
Uh now there's there's another couple of
ingredients that are not mentioned in
those verses. One ingredient is the
spirit
>> because uh uh for each church it says he
who has an ear, let him hear what the
spirit says to the churches.
>> Correct?
>> Uh and another missing ingredient is in
verse four where it says John to the
seven churches. So when you put
everything together, you have God giving
the message to Jesus Christ, Jesus
Christ giving the message to the Holy
Spirit, his representative on earth. And
then the Holy Spirit gives it to the
angel.
The angel gives it to John.
John sends it to the seven churches.
>> And then of course the seven churches
are supposed to proclaim it to the
world. Mhm.
>> So God doesn't do everything directly
himself.
>> Mhm.
>> He delegates responsibility.
>> Right.
>> Now God knows everything from the
beginning from eternity. God knows
everything that has ever happened on
this earth from the time creation took
place till the end. I mean and
everything before. Mhm.
>> So God doesn't have to be present here
right now to know what we're saying,
>> right?
>> Because from eternity past, he already
knew that we were going to be here be
here and we were going to be saved. Now,
that doesn't mean that he determined
that. It means that he knew that we were
going to choose to be here,
>> right?
>> He knew everything that was going to
happen by choices that were made,
>> right?
>> He doesn't determine, but he knows. Mhm.
>> Now, there's one psalm, Psalm 139, that
is usually spoken of as the psalm of the
omniresence of God.
>> I believe that that's a mis a mis uh
misnomer.
>> It's not the psalm about the
omnipresence of God. It's a psalm about
the omniscience of God. The fact that
God knows everything. He is present
everywhere because he knows everything.
>> And um so maybe um if you could read
>> um Psalm 139 and we'll begin at verse
one and I'll stop you each time that you
get to the key verse.
>> Absolutely. It says, "Oh Lord, you have
searched me and known me."
>> Stop. Known me. Okay, keep on reading.
>> You know my
>> Okay, stop. You know
>> my sitting down and my rising up.
>> You understand?
>> Mhm. My thought a far off.
>> Oh, a far off. Okay.
>> You comprehend
>> comprehend
>> my path and my laying down and are
acquainted
>> acquainted. Okay.
>> With all my ways. And there is not a
word on my tongue. But behold, O Lord,
you know it.
>> Know it. Okay. Good. together.
>> Now, let's stop there just for a moment.
>> What comes to mind when you say, "God
has known me. You know my sitting down.
You understand my thought. A far off.
You comprehend. You are acquainted. You
know it." It's talking about his his
knowledge.
>> Yes.
>> It's talking about his omniscience.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not talking about his omnipresence.
>> Exactly. But then people take one verse
and they say that one verse is talk is
is saying that this is dealing with with
omnipresence and uh and that is uh verse
seven.
>> Yes.
>> It says where can I go from your spirit
or where can I flee from your presence
>> and then continue
>> if I ascend into heaven you are there.
If I make my bed in hell behold you are
there.
>> Okay stop there. Uh so God is there
right?
How is he there?
>> Is the knowledge
>> because he doesn't have to be there.
>> Yeah. Basically, he has to be there.
>> He's sit God is sitting on his throne.
>> Yeah.
>> In heaven. That's the reason why we pray
our father which are in heaven.
>> You know, he's not God is not like some
substance that permeates everywhere.
>> He doesn't have to be everywhere. That's
that's an important point because if you
if you develop that thought then you you
you turn into a pantheistic kind of God
of course
>> who's an everywhere and everything. I I
and I want to let you get back on your
horse here but I have I have always
settled it in my mind is that God is not
everywhere but everywhere is in his
presence. In other words in this room
>> this room we can see everything that's
happening in this room
>> because it's in our presence. I know
it's you're here. I know that you are
here. I know the cameras are there.
Well, if you take that and extrapolate
and expand that to the universe, then
you have God. He's aware of what's going
on, but he doesn't have to be in every
nook and cranny in every little place to
be God. He's just aware of what's
happening. The world is in his presence,
right? As opposed to as opposed to his
presence being everywhere.
>> He lives in an eternal present. That's
why he's the I am. You know, we look at
history in segments, past, present, and
future. But God has everything right
before his eyes as if it's happening
right now.
>> And that's why uh you know Jesus said
all live to him
>> for God all the all the righteous have
already resurrected.
>> Yes.
>> Because he sees it as a done deal. Now
uh I want to read a couple of statements
from Ellen White where Ellen White
refers in the first statement to Psalm
139. Mhm.
>> The psalmist represents the presence of
the infinite one as pervading the
universe. I see there he's omnipresent.
Well, let's just wait. If I ascend up to
heaven, thou art there. If I make my bed
in hell, behold, thou art there. She's
quoting Psalm 139.
We can never find a solitude where God
is not. Now comes the key. People don't
read carefully.
>> So once again, she says the ever wa Um,
we can never find a solitude where God
is not. The ever watchful eye of
omniscience
>> is upon all our works. And although we
can marshall the he cannot marshall the
armies of heaven to do his will, he
condescends to accept the services of
frail airing mortals. There it explains
how God is everywhere.
>> It says the watchful eye of omniscience
is upon all our works. And then there's
another statement, ministry of healing
4:17.
The Bible shows us God in his high and
holy place, not in a state of
inactivity, not in silence and solitude,
but surrounded by 10,000 times 10,000
and thousands of thousands of holy
beings. How important are those beings?
Well, notice what she says. All waiting
to do his will. Mhm.
>> And then she states through these
messengers,
he that is God is in active
communication with every part of his
dominion.
>> He's not in every part of his dominion.
>> Correct?
>> Through these messengers, he is in every
part of his dominion in active
communication. And then she explains
by his spirit, he is everywhere present.
But the Holy Spirit uses the angels.
Mhm.
>> And then it says, "Through the agency of
his spirit and his angels, he ministers
to the children of men." So let's take
one example. The the servant of the
centurion that was healed. It's a
powerful example.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, the centurion says, "I have
this uh servant that is gravely ill."
And Jesus, oh, I'll go and heal him. And
uh he says, "No need. you don't have to
come. Just speak the word and it will be
done.
>> And then he he understood better than
better than than the Jews.
>> Yeah.
>> He said because I'm also a man of
authority.
>> I'm going to tell this soldier go do
this. I tell this soldier go do that.
>> And Ellen White commenting on this,
>> she says that the angel was on his way
to the bed of the of the servant
>> to heal him.
>> Yeah. So, so it's not that the word of
Jesus is flying through the air, the the
the im immaterial word. No, he did.
Ellen White says that all his miracles
>> were performed by the power of God
through the ministry of the angels.
Let me give you another example. Um,
you know, who who inspired the writings
of Ellen White? We believe that she was
inspired by the Holy Spirit, right?
But she spoke of my messenger, my guide,
my angel.
>> Who gave dreams to the prophets in the
Bible? Well, it was the angels. You say,
"Well, then the Holy Spirit didn't do
it." No, the Holy Spirit did it through
the angels.
Just because he didn't do it, you know,
it's like, for example, we uh we have a
builder of houses in Fresno. And so we
say uh you know this person person built
all this neighborhood of houses. Well,
excuse me.
You know the name the name of the person
is on the sign. It says houses built by
but that person didn't build all the
houses.
>> No.
>> But he did give the instructions of
where to build them, how to build them.
Yes.
>> He gave the plans. And and Ellen White
also says for example that uh um
the father makes his thoughts audible
through the son.
>> And and so we need to understand that
that God is sitting on his throne.
Christ is there interceding.
The Holy Spirit is on earth working
through the ministry of the angels. Uh
and and the church has benefited. Mhm.
>> So God does not operate a dictatorship.
>> God delegates responsibility.
>> That's why he has a heavenly council.
>> In fact, Ellen White has a statement
where she says that it was not God's
decision only to expel Satan from
heaven, Lucifer from heaven. She says
that he consulted with the heavenly
council and the heavenly council said
expel him.
But but we usually think of God as being
the one who does absolutely everything.
>> But God uh runs a re a a a a republic
style of governance. In other words, now
could God do it all by himself? Of
course he could. But he doesn't operate
that way.
And thank you pastor because this
concept of the chain of command as you
would have said it really illustrates
how the godhead operates and how the
angels operate and how we receive the
information and how we are to share it
with others as well. So there is this
chain of command that it really defines
and helps us understand some of the
questions that he has this individual
had in regards to how the Lord works and
operates and you don't have to be
physically anywhere. I mean everywhere.
God doesn't have to be physically father
everywhere to understand and to know
everything. He has knowledge of all
things
>> and that's how he can be aware of
everything in a sense know all or be
there but is not necessarily physically
there and and answering the question as
far as uh he relies on his fornowledge
uh to a certain degree he does he like
we just by showing this exchange of
command it's very clearly defined how
god operates and he knows all things but
he delegates the functions right
>> to the proper channels of operation so
that all heaven all the universe is
working in this particular case in
redemption of man. So it is wonderful to
see that and I think this will help our
friend to understand clearly what what
that means and and connecting to the uh
question of revelation 5:6 again the
symbols of Jesus is really showing the
features or the concept of how he knows
or how he works through this chain of
command and where he's at because he's
actually the one that receives from the
father the revelation and he delegates
it to the holy spirit to give it to the
angels and the angels to the servants or
to the prophet to prophets and then to
us the churches And and that's how it
works.
>> In fact, it's an awesome thought that
the father actually gave the book of
revelation to Jesus.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh maybe I can give another example of
this. Uh did God know
what Satan was going to do in the days
of Esther to try and get rid of the
Jewish nation?
>> Of course he did.
>> He knew that.
>> Yeah.
>> So So God knows everything that Satan is
going to do. Mhm.
>> So God is able to counteract what Satan
has plans to do. You know, God knew
everything what the devil was going to
do to influence uh the Hmon, you know,
to influence the king to give the decree
to kill all the Jews. So what did God
do? He says, "Well, I'll just put Esther
in in the palace before that happens.
I'll influence the king to to choose
Esther. And that way, Satan will not
fulfill his will. I will fulfill my
will.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, and so Satan, there's no way
Satan can win.
>> Yeah.
>> Because he has to guess how God is going
to play,
>> but God already knows how he's going to
play. So God can take the steps to
counteract what he's doing.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so the omniscience of God guarantees
the victory of God ultimately.
>> Absolutely. You know, when when you look
at Revelation uh the the text that you
read there, I I see testimony of Jesus
as part of the the line. Of course, the
testimony of Jesus, you go to Revelation
19:10, the spirit of prophecy. Um
>> I think we have underestimated Pastor
Bor, Pastor Salazar, the the ministry,
the role, the function of angels in this
whole plan.
>> Yes.
>> Um in the book, the gospel uh as written
by John, all of the miracles are Zoom
miracles. By that I mean they're all
remote. Christ didn't go in and lay
hands on anybody in John.
>> They're all uh remote miracles, you
know. Uh so somebody had to be the
functionary there, you know. Somebody
had to actually do it because Christ
wasn't there. Christ said it, it
happened over there, you know, uh the
the center and said, "Say it, it'll
happen over there." Uh so there had to
be a a a functional end to that. So we
have underestimated my pastor my friend
uh the role of angels in this whole uh
scheme of of the salv salvation of men
and women.
>> You know I've dedicated many many years
to this particular subject.
>> Um you have for example the tower of
babel.
>> Yeah.
>> Who confused the languages.
Well uh you read Genesis it says the
Lord God
>> confused the languages and spread them
all across the earth.
But it's interesting that Ellen White
has a statement where she says that God
sent two angels
>> to confuse their language,
>> right?
>> So who gave the gift of tongues at the
Tower of Babel?
It was God through the angels. Angels.
Now the same is true at Pentecost.
>> Yes.
>> The angels were involved in the gift of
tongues at Pentecost. Let me just read
you a couple of statements here.
Jesus Ellen White is writing to someone.
All heaven is interested in your
salvation and angels of God are waiting
to do for you what they did for the
early disciples on the day of Pentecost.
>> Here's another one. Uh this is Marinatha
page 212. Before the work is closed up
and the sealing of God's people is
finished, we shall receive the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit. Angels
from heaven will be in our midst.
>> Interesting.
and and and I have several other
statements where where she says that the
angels were directly involved
>> at Pentecost.
>> Yes.
>> Now, if the angels imparted the gift of
tongues or um you know a um a capacity
to speak a language that they had never
spoken before perfectly, perfect
grammar, etc.
>> Um then the angels probably were did it
also at Pentecost. Mhm.
>> So the angels are the link between the
Holy Spirit and human beings
and and I have a series of long many
many statements where Ellen White all of
the work that the Holy Spirit attributes
uh that the word of God attributes to
the Holy Spirit Ellen White uh
attributes to the angels but the angels
are not the Holy Spirit. They the Holy
Spirit delegates to them. Mhm.
>> And uh you know it's kind of like uh the
Apostle Paul resurrecting
>> Udicus.
>> Well, holy who resurrected Udicus? Well,
you know, it wasn't Paul,
>> but God gave God delegated to him the
ability to to call him from death. And
of course, the power of God resurrected
him. So, um I hope this is helpful.
>> Absolutely. It does give us new insight
into the work of angels, the ministry of
angels, the the role and function of
angels, and the importance of angels in
the salvific process. We are down to our
last several minutes. Hopefully, we can
get this question in from Deborah in
Woodlon, Tennessee. Uh I aimed this
question at Pastor Boris. So, this one
is is aimed right right at you, pastor.
Um I just heard one of my longtime
favorite estate pastors. She doesn't
name him because she says we all know
him. Um he said on the program that
Armageddon is when Satan urges all the
powers of earth to gather to battle and
destroy the remnant when God sends the
seventh plague and then destroys them. I
have understood uh I believe you pastor
B taught that Armageddon is actually a
final attempt of Satan to overtake God's
people and the new Jerusalem after the
millennium. Um,
I'm not fearful nor do I consider it
vital. Uh, and and then she just
justifies her question. So, let's walk
our way through that uh rather than take
more time with the question. Uh, since
it's aimed at you, I'll give you a first
shot.
>> The plagues are explicitly before the
second coming.
>> Yes.
>> I mean, it's the sixth plague, sixth and
seventh plague. Uh, where you have the
battle of Armageddon. The sixth plague
is the preparation for the battle
>> and then the seventh plague is the
battle itself when Christ comes with the
armies of heaven.
>> Right?
>> Uh so uh so there's no doubt whatsoever
that Armageddon in context
is dealing with u the battle of the
wicked against God's people. In other
words, it's a battle against God in the
person of his people.
>> And that that takes place before the
second coming of Christ. Okay? And God's
people are delivered. They're delivered
from the death decree
>> when the sixth plague dries up the
multitudes on the harlot and they turn
against her.
>> Okay.
>> However, there's more to the story. What
took place with the religious leaders
before the second coming is going to
take place with the leader of those
religious of the leader of the whole
movement Satan after the millennium.
>> Exactly.
>> So I've usually said that uh what
happens after the millennium is kind of
like the second stage
of the battle of Armageddon. That's
where our question comes
>> because what happens after after what
happens after the second coming,
>> right?
>> After the second coming,
>> Satan is going to gather all the wicked
>> around the city.
>> Yes.
>> He's not going to reveal himself as
Satan. He's going to reveal himself as a
prince. Ellen White says this in the
last chapter of Great Controversy. He's
going to say, "Those inside, they've
usurped my kingdom, you know, but we're
lots of people. We can conquer them."
And he's going to deceive them into
prepare for battle. millions and
millions of of of individuals.
>> But then God in panoramic view is going
to show over the city the true story,
the true history, and they're going to
see how Satan was behind the deceptions.
And then instead of destroying God's
people,
>> they're turning to him.
>> They're going to turn against him.
>> So they turn against the leader after
the millennium
as the multitudes turned against the
religious leaders before the millennium.
But technically speaking,
uh the battle of Armageddon is uh before
the second coming when uh the wicked who
have been deceived the by the religious
leaders turn against them.
>> Thank you. There is there are two
battles and that's where sometimes the
confusion comes in. Thank you Deborah
for your question. Again, our time has
gotten away from us. Hopefully this
program has been a blessing to you.
We'll see you again soon. Bye-bye and
God bless.